[Music]
[Music]
i've done five videos you have those
hand-to-hand fight videos and those
showcases of power videos but i felt
i've neglected something and indeed i
have i've yet to do a video to show some
of my favorite super power fights in
anime so that's what we're gonna do
today but hey watching top superpower
fights in anime is a cool thing you know
what's even cooler being able to do so
in a browser tailor made for anime
enthusiasts and gamers a lot like us
introducing today's sponsor opera gx
opera gx is the next gen evolution of
the opera browser bringing with it a
whole lot of features that we can't wait
to get our hands on you know stuff that
enhances the viewing experience and
allows you to show your love for anime
as much as you can such as themes for
one opera gx prides itself in being a
browser that lives for customization of
themes so whether you're a one-piece fan
who'd like to be greeted by this amazing
art of the thousand sunny
or a person of culture who can't wait to
have this gorgeous animated chernobyl
wallpaper
opera gx has it for you and the fun's
just getting started multitaskers would
love this next feature as opera gx also
allows some cool tricks such as pop-out
videos that way you can keep browsing
some of your favorite anime threads
while watching your episodes in a
floating adjustable video frame and
integration has never been easier with
the gx player which allows integration
to spotify apple music youtube music and
other streaming platforms never miss a
beat as you connect to those apps and
even your own computer with the quick
import tool that allows you to import
all information from your previous
browser with a couple of clicks take the
leap and download this browser for the
next generation through the link in the
description box be ahead of the pack
with opera gx let's kick things off at
full power with shimazuki versus
everyone
i've talked about several different mob
psycho fights in my videos well not as
much as the more mainstream shonen ones
because that's what you guys mostly like
still how can i stop ranting and raving
about mother psycho fights when it
features some of the most visually
spectacular battles the anime world has
given us i did notice however that i've
yet to talk about this battle in the
series second season shimazaki taking on
everyone was a treat to watch thanks to
the breathtaking animation you really
get the feel of the fight and you get to
indulge in the impact of it all it's one
thing to passively show you something
but it's another thing to show
shimazaki's dominance in such a way that
you get pulled into it following the
action
if you're up for another showcase of
strength meliodus versus the
commandments is just the right one for
you
instead of a fight this could be more of
a melioda's flex montage when he tries
to go one man army against the entire
squad doesn't matter what the
commandments threw at him he always
found a way to persevere through it all
an awesome looking answer at that with
him using those attacks as a source of
strength smugly taking them all for him
to unleash an even more powerful attack
that would surely eradicate all of them
i consider this a legendary moment in
the series a fight to remember not
because of how intense it was but
because it more than represents the
theme seven deadly sins has with the
whack power levels and endurance of its
characters but the flex isn't all there
is to it we all got our hearts ripped
out when esther rossa steps in and puts
an end to it what follows is a moment
that will be forever remembered as
meliodus outright dies yes even godlike
beings fall and it happening to the main
character who had all the momentum on
his side not too long ago was all the
more shocking
[Applause]
we move to something recent now and one
of the best animated episodes of one
piece
with how long one piece has been going
on it's no surprise that there'd be lots
of memorable even legendary fights
involved in the world's creative
roulette of superpowers for this video i
want to take something a bit more modern
and i decided on kaido and big mom
versus luffy lore kid and zorro this
insanely animated battle is one of the
highlights of this arc it's one of my
favorite gear for moments for luffy it's
also emblematic of the whole crazy out
of this world gimmicks and styles that
one piece boasts it's an anime bound by
no limits and you see it with how big of
a deal wano arc has become in terms of
production all of them juted out given
they're all showcasing their endurance
tactics and powers yeah i know this
battle is far from over but watching
this scene animated just increased my
expectation for the rest of the fight
fma's final battle is here and
deservingly so
fma is not particularly the flashy
superpower type of show at least the
alchemy and magic isn't the main appeal
of it all that brought it such a claim
but the final showdown with father does
deserve some more love it basically
starts off demonstrating how powerful
fathers become that no matter how many
forces combined to form a united front
no matter how many kinds of powers get
thrown at him it's all just meaningless
how do you beat something like this
after all the physical embodiment of a
god standing in front of all these
humans desperately fighting for survival
however we soon see cracks opening up
and it leads to one of the most powerful
moments in fma the final showdown with
ed the final clash with ed is something
more than a battle it's a dissection of
father's ideals and representation of
his fitting downfall it's also filled
with irony just like how it's ironic
that a fight that features one of the
most powerful characters with all the
superpowers ends with a good old punch
to the chest it's not quite the showcase
of superpowers that you'll probably come
to expect from this list further adding
to the irony of things in a meta
perspective but it's the best end to an
epic final battle that we can have for
fma
here's a movie battle for the next entry
midoriya and barcugo versus nine
now i personally have a lot of positive
opinions about the my hero academia
movies they're not exactly manga canon
but they find themselves nestled right
in between arcs making some seamless
transitions into actual canon material
anyway i love the first movie but i
think the second movie heroes rising
isn't talked about as much as it should
be or maybe i'm just not around the mha
community as much i'm not even sure
whether this climax is a cut above the
first ones both are equally good but at
least this movie gave us the awesome
team up between midoriya and bakugo it's
such a well done scene then fighting
against nine with a lot of hype moments
culminating of course in bakugo getting
a taste of something he'd always wanted
one for all the fight against nine is
standard superhero super power action
but the finality of it all but google's
character arc somehow finding a sort of
conclusion in this movie that's what
makes this one so good of course they
had to revert to the status quo in the
end because it's what an anime movie
does but damn that was such a sweet
scene the presentation including the
animation the music and the voice acting
it was all just on point this is
probably one of the best fights in the
franchise including the tv series we
proceed now with bleach's ichigo vs all
kiyora
if you were to ask me what my favorite
fight in the whole aaron carr arc was
it's got to be this one there are lots
of contenders sure but could they
compare to the build-up and the roller
coaster of emotions that this fight took
bleach fans through i don't think so
things started out even and everyone's
pretty hyped to see ichigo and okiyora
fight as equals this time then it takes
a whole turn for the worse on and on it
goes drowning even ichigo and orihime
down the pits of despair only for hope
to come in ichigo's revival in new form
but something just doesn't feel quite
right here you get what i mean it
follows the usual hyped fight formula
but this is the one fight where the ray
of hope that comes in the form of a new
protagonist form feels uh feels a little
bit wrong somehow it's all thanks to
ichigo's monstrous new form i wouldn't
be surprised if someone comes into the
end of the fight blind and thinks that
ichigo's the villain in this fight
between two demonic beings with how
ruthless he's become and when all kia
ora does bite the dust right as he looks
like he's about to start a redemption
arc we're left feeling hollow no pun
intended
gogeta vs broly is up next
i couldn't wait to talk about this fight
the sheer excitement the hype and the
eventual collision all made the first
broly movie one of the favorite pieces
of dragon ball media it was something
special and we all knew it when we first
saw it decades later gogeta and broly
take on each other again and they
haven't lost a step in 2018. what more
can i say about this fight besides the
fact that it's one of those fights
heavily carried by the hype and the
context there's not a lot of derivatives
of the word awesome that you can use to
describe this collision of titans and
the new paths from super up the power
scaling even more compared to the two
first runs at it if anything it
showcases broly's power to the point
that gogeta had to go blue to win
decisively at that overall it's an
awesome fight that both longtime and
returning dragon ball fans have got to
see
[Music]
superpowers mixed with a lot of martial
arts how about yuji and todo versus
hanami next
the first real test for a newly formed
bond the states being as high as they
can towards the climax of the fight
there's a lot of things that make this
fight so much hype that it more than
lived up to it thanks to fight
choreography that's out of this world
each phase of the battle was masterfully
presented and it felt awesome to see
yuji and todo put that fresh chemistry
into work as they team up to take on
what's the toughest enemy they've faced
so far their techniques meshing proved
to be a match for hanami and for most of
the duration of the fight it seems that
things could go either way however
there's one factor that turns the tides
a factor that the characters may not
have remembered thanks to the heat of
the battle the one and only gojo our
favorite mentor makes an appearance
towards the end joining the fight in the
only way he can by revealing a new
astonishing technique that easily
defeats hanami i feel that a lot of
people don't remember this as much as
the first domain training session moment
but hollow purple easily ranks as one of
gojo's best moments
if i were to pick a battle in the fate
series i think that shiro and ryder vs
sabre alter takes the k
at some point in the back of my head i
still love the two ubw fights to death
shiro vs gil was one of the most
satisfying final fights in anime that
i've ever watched especially coming off
phase zero meanwhile the fight versus
archer with last stardust served as
shiro's coronation and still gives me
goosebumps thinking about it however
we're here talking about superpowered
fights and there's no better
representation of the flash and
fireworks of the mainline fate series
than the one in the final heavens feel
movie this is nothing short of what we'd
expect from ufo tables fate epic
post-production effects a lot of flashes
and quick frantic action that our mortal
eyes struggle to follow all of these
combine to elevate a battle to the next
level to drive home the point of how
cataclysmic everything is it's something
we won't last a second in and the
presentation more than sends that
message home at the end of it all this
battle didn't even end up being the true
final fight of the movie i do think it's
fitting however while the previous two
routes showcase a lot more fights
heaven's feel is just a more muted and
profound experience it's not the fights
that grip us in this series of movies
but the more philosophical questions
that they throw at us lastly what better
way to top it all off than with naruto
versus sasuke
best and most legendary fight in all of
anime i mean it's not exactly something
that even i would boldly proclaim
especially with the number of amazing
fights we've covered so far seriously
something like the fight right before
this could have beat it in terms of
fireworks but in terms of choreography
we also have a couple of ones who can
make a case too like the jujutsu kaizen
one heck even with naruto there are
contenders too however what naruto
versus sasuke has compared to them all
is the build-up this is the fight that's
literally over a decade in the making
the fight to end all fights in naruto
everyone knew it was gonna happen but
the whole thing's surrounding it the
storyline the fight is peaking just at
the right time and the stakes it makes
it one fight that naruto fans deserve
and all the two needed to do was to put
on a show and make the decade-long wait
worth it and they sure did a
long-standing rivalry that stood the
test of world ending threats finally
concluded in an intense battle of powers
and ideals and it ended in the best
possible way a tactical draw on the
physical side of things but a clear
victor in the battle of ideals the right
person won and it's such a great
conclusion to a legendary series
and that concludes my list i was
thinking of ranking them at first but i
decide against it because how can we
really rank these equally amazing fights
they all have their own cases to be the
best fights in their own ways and i
think it's better if i just let you rank
them yourself say how would you do it
then do you have a fight that you want
to add to the list i'd love to hear from
your thoughts on the comments section
that or you could drop by the channel
social media too discord instagram
patreon come on you know the drill all
the links are in the description box to
give you easier access and don't forget
to check out opera gx browser through
the link in the description box download
it free of charge and it opens up a
whole new window of possibilities thank
you for watching this video i hope you
have a great day ahead and look forward
to seeing you next time